das ist der teuerste Zug der Welt und
ein Ticket kostet über 900 Mal so viel
wie ein regionalbahnticket von Köln nach
Aachen obwohl die Bahn langsamer fährt
im Zug erwartet uns zu viel Champagner
wie wir trinken wollen ein eigenes
Zimmer mit Badezimmer und Dusche
verschiedene Restaurants und noch vieles
mehr man müsste also völlig bescheuert
sein um extra für diesen Zug nach
Venedig zu fahren und 17.000 € für ein
Ticket zu bezahlen ja was soll ich sagen
[Musik]
viel Spaß mit dem teuersten Video dass
ich jemals produziert habe losgehen die
experience schon im Hotel wir wurden
persönlich abgeholt mit einem Boot und
durch Venedig Kanäle zum Bahnhof
gebracht die komplette experience hat
hier im Hotel schon gestartet wir wurden
in Empfang genommen also es ist wirklich
unglaublich und in dieser Kulisse jetzt
mit dem Boot zum Bahnhof zu fahren um
quasi einen halben Wagon für sich
alleine zu haben ist echt völlig
unglaublich also mir fehlen wirklich die
Worte es ist richtig krass ab dem Hotel
mussten wir uns quasi um nichts mehr
kümmern die Dame dessen einziger Job es
war und sicher und pünktlich zum Zug zu
bringen nutzte uns durch das
touristische Gedränge und das Gepäck
wurde uns abgenommen damit es direkt
aufs Zimmer gebracht werden konnte und
dort stand Ändern der luxuriöseste Zug
der Welt
simplon-express
auf dem Weg zu unserem Waggon wurden wir
dann von jedem einzelnen der 41
Servicekräfte gegrüßt die sich in den
nächsten 22 Stunden und unser
Wohlergehen können
das ist Gloria sie ist unsere Kevin
Stewardess und zuständig alleine für
unseren Wagen sie ist 24/7 erreichbar um
uns jeden Wunsch von den Lippen
abzulesen und dabei super sympathisch
und zuvorkommt
richtig gehört wenn es grand Suite der
Zug besteht aus drei verschiedenen
Klassen Historiker die günstigste Klasse
einfaches kleines dennoch elegantes
Zimmer mit Klappbetten und einem
Waschbecken die sweets Doppelbett mit
privater Dusche und WC das hat uns aber
nicht gereicht wir haben uns für das
größte Ticket die größte sweet
entschieden und testen heute für euch
ein 17 000 € Zugticket die Grand sweet
so groß dass nur drei von ihnen in einem
Waggon passen und sie mit Abstand die
teuerste klasse ist
was zur Hölle ist das wir wurden die
ganze Zeit begleitet und sind jetzt auf
dem Weg in unseren Suite aber ich weiß
nicht warum es reingeht
hi thank you wow
[Musik]
ich weiß gar nicht was ich sagen soll
ich will euch noch nicht zu viel von dem
Zimmer zeigen da werden wir natürlich
gleich noch komplett drauf eingehen und
ja ihr habt richtig gehört ein Zimmer
das ganze ist nämlich ein schlafzug man
kann so ziemlich überall in Europa
hinfahren wir haben uns für die Strecke
von Venedig nach Paris entschieden die
ungefähr 22 Stunden dauert und was uns
hier sonst noch alles erwarten wird das
erzähle ich euch jetzt zuallererst haben
wir eine Einführung in die unzähligen
Funktionen und Knöpfe der Stream
bekommen
Figuren da sind
window this is your ready found it the
blue button for me like my Unicorn so
anything you need you can pres this
Butter also so viel kann man schon mal
sagen unheimlich guter Service also
wirklich super nett super lieb hat
gefühlt so ihren Service Stil direkt an
uns angepasst super easy locker also
gefällt mir richtig gut macht richtig
Laune und noch bevor wir losfahren wir
stehen noch im Hauptbahnhof von Venedig
haben wir Champagner und obstplatte
gerecht bekommen das sieht hier wirklich
verboten gut aus also es ist unglaublich
außerdem kam in der Küchenchef vorbei
und hat gefragt wann wir gerne essen
wollen es fühlt sich wirklich ein
bisschen falsch an aber wir werden
probieren das den vollen Zügen zu
genießen wenn das ganze hat ja auch ist
sein Preis
[Musik]
das war jetzt gerade ein bisschen S-Bahn
Feeling sage ich ehrlich ein
unglaublicher Empfang der nur erahnen
lässt wie luxuriös die nächsten 22
Stunden in diesem Zimmer werden würden
was soll ich sagen 17.000 Euro sind
einfach komplett over the top das würde
bedeuten dass eine Stunde 772 Euro und
jede Minute dieser Zugfahrt 12,80 €
kostet was komplett bescheuert ist egal
wie viel Champagner wir trinken egal was
der zu bieten hat dieser Preis ist in
keiner Welt zu rechtfert und vielleicht
kennt Ihr das auch ihr habt in der
Vergangenheit irgendwelche finanziellen
Fehler Entscheidungen getroffen und
irgendwas gekauft was eigentlich gar
nicht eurem Budget entspricht und euch
für einen Ratenzahlung und damit eine
verbrauche Kredit entschieden aber kein
Problem in die finden unterstützt nicht
nur mich und dieses Video sondern auch
euch mit eurem raten oder Kredit Problem
fürs neue Jahr sollte seine Schulden
loszuwerden und deine Finanzen in den
Griff zu bekommen ist dabei der absolut
richtige erste Schritt das gesamte
Angebot von anifin richtet sich an Leute
die bereits in einem Kredit drin hängen
also schon verschuldet sind durch die
App herunter um dort die letzte raten
oder Kreditkarten abrechnen muss zu
sagen
Bedingungen und schaut ob es irgendeine
Möglichkeit gibt euren Kredit günstiger
zu machen wenn das der Fall ist und auch
wirklich nur wenn das der Fall ist
bekommt ihr ein Angebot und könnt euch
dann entscheiden ob ihr es annehmen
wollt oder nicht das ganze ist komplett
kostenlos und absolut unverbindlich und
wenn ihr euch fragt wie das funktioniert
dann habe ich jetzt die Antwort für euch
Andy finden sorgt dafür dass euer Kredit
auf einmal abgezahlt wird wodurch ihr
euch in vielen Fällen ein Angebot mit
weniger Zinsen machen können
gleichzeitig wird es dadurch deutlich
flexibler ihr könnt euch selber
einstellen in welchem Tempo ihr
zurückzahlen wollt und bis zu zwei Raten
um euch aber auch langfristig zu helfen
schönen frei zu bleiben gibt es in der
anifin App eine Möglichkeit mit wenigen
Klicks super schnell eure Kreditkarte zu
kündigen so nehmt ihr euch selber die
Möglichkeit super einfach irgendwas auf
Pumpen kaufen zu können und bleibt
langfristig schuldenfrei klickt also
jetzt auf den ersten Link in der
Videobeschreibung ladet euch eine von
runter und benutzt für 20 € Rabatt auf
eure erste Ratenzahlung fangt an eure
aufzuräumen vielen Dank an die finden
dieses Video möglich gemacht haben und
euch viel Spaß weiter mit dem Video
[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen all das was
ihr hinter mir seht ist tatsächlich
unser Privatzimmer und wenn es Simplon
Orient Express
ungefähr ein Drittel eines kompletten
Waggons ist diese großweed groß also
dann wirklich das Größte was überhaupt
möglich ist wir haben ein Wohnbereich
wir haben ein eigenes Badezimmer mit
eigener Dusche werden den Schlafbereich
Leo steht gerade schon richtig im
Eingangsbereich direkt neben dem
Eingangsbereich befindet sich das Sofa
ist in der sweet nur für zwei Leute
Platz aber man könnte auch mit mehr
Leuten hier sitzen würde man also mit
einer größeren Gruppe reisen und es
wären mehrere Suiten hier äh in diesem
Zug gebucht könnte man in einer Suite
mit mehreren Leuten oder mit mehr Leuten
als zwei auf jeden Fall noch
zusammenkommen anders als beim Esstisch
wo wir gerade eben schon gegessen haben
das hattet ihr schon gesehen wir haben
einen treffsessel und ein etwas
kleineren Sessel zwei Leute finden hier
Platz hier werden Snacks gereicht aber
nicht nur Snacks sondern auch endlos
Champagner in dem Ticketpreis mit
inbegriffen ist
24/7 Service zum einen und 24 7 so viel
Champagner wie wir trinken können oder
wollen mit Sicherheit könnten wir auch
veranlassen dass wir hier unser Essen zu
uns nehmen das wollen wir aber nicht wir
wollen euch an die verschiedenen
Restaurants zeigen deswegen werden wir
das nicht machen neben dem Essbereich
befindet sich direkt die Minibar also da
findet man so ziemlich alles was das
Herz begehrt und alles ist im Griff
weiter es ist groß hier ist es
riesengroß ich würde sagen Zimmer ist
ziemlich genau 2 m breit und inklusive
des Bades so 6 m lang und bevor wir
jetzt zum Highlight dem riesengroßen
Schlafzimmer kommen also es ist
tatsächlich quasi ein eigenes Zimmer
schauen wir uns als erstes mal das
vollwertige Bad an dass ich auch hier in
der großen befindet
[Musik]
zum Bad oder zur Suite dazu gab es zwei
Bademäntel die wir behalten dürfen wenn
wir keine Lust haben die nach dem Zug
direkt mitzunehmen hat sich schon gesagt
können wir einfach ein Formular
ausfüllen und die Bademantel werden dann
als Geschenk Herr Post zu uns nach Hause
geschickt das sehr nett wir haben eine
vollwertige Toilette also wirklich
komplett vollwertig es ist sauber das
komplette Bad ist marmoriert überall in
dem kompletten Zimmer sind 13
Materialien alle Armaturen sind golden
ich weiß jetzt nicht ob die vergoldet
oder ob das in irgendeiner Weise echtes
Gold ist wir haben sogar eine Arsch
Dusche vielleicht werde ich damit auch
zum ersten Mal auf dieser Reise
Bekanntschaften macht dann natürlich ein
vollwertiges Waschbecken mit kaltem und
warmem Wasser da kommt jetzt auch nicht
nur so ein bisschen raus wie man das aus
der RE9 zwischen 7 und Aachen kennt so
drei Tropfen wo man probiert nichts
anderes zu berühren und man sich
eigentlich die Hände schmutziger macht
als wenn man es einfach nicht benutzen
würde hier kommt tatsächlich Wasser raus
und zwar so viel dass wir auch Platz und
genug Wasser für eine voll wertige
Dusche haben selbst in diesem Zug haben
sie eine bodentiefe Dusche hinbekommen
also hätten wir das im Wohnungsprojekt
nicht hinbekommen dann würde ich mich
bei jedem dieser Ansichten sehr schlecht
fühlen aber eine bodentiefe Dusche auch
wieder Gold Armaturen super schick und
vor allem einfach eine Menge Platz wir
werden natürlich hier schlafen und ich
kann mir wirklich nicht geileres
vorstellen in komplett frischen Sachen
komplett frisch geduscht Morgen aus dem
Zug hier wieder auszusteigen oder
vielleicht sogar heute abend mich dann
frisch geduscht ins Bett zu legen wenn
es übrigens ein gutes Stichwort weil das
schauen wir uns als nächstes also eine
Sache noch falls ihr euch gefragt habt
warum ich mit Anzug und Hemd und so
komplett auf Schnösel Wave hier diesen
Zug fahre es gibt eine Kleiderordnung
die uns genau das vorschreibt es ist
nicht erlaubt mit Jeans oder Jogginghose
oder irgendwie sowas ähnlichem hier den
Zug zu betreten was man hier im Zimmer
macht ist natürlich einem selbst
überlassen aber einem wird der Eintritt
im Restaurant und in den Fluren verwehrt
wenn man nicht mindestens Business
Casual gekleidet ist man merkt dass die
Leute die hier mitfahren gerne auch
möchten dass dieses Bild gewahrt wird
und sie für 24 Stunden quasi komplett in
die volle wenn es Simplon Orient
experience eintauchen können und jetzt
aber wirklich zum absoluten Herzstück
dem Bett und damit auch dem Schlafzimmer
dieses zu machen
wir haben in dieser sweet ein komplett
vollwertiges Bett für zwei Personen wir
haben nachttischschränke mit Stauraum
bin hier das Personal rufen falls wir
heute mitten in der Nacht Champagner
bestellen wollen der natürlich komplett
kostenlos ist wir haben einen komplett
zu öffnen des Fenster also wir können
uns wenn wir wollen hier aus diesem
Fenster raushängen und die frische Fahrt
Luft genießen und vor allem können wir
aber richtig krass abchecken auch hier
natürlich feinste Materialien Textil
Holz es fühlt sich alles super gut an
auch die Kissen fühlen sich super an den
verschiedenen Härtegraden all das hätten
wir vorher auch noch auswählen können
wir wurden gefragt was essen wollen was
wir vielleicht nicht essen wollen ob wir
irgendw okay Allergien haben inwiefern
sie dieses gesamte Zimmer und die
komplette experience auf uns anpassen
wollen ob wir das Ganze für ein Event
machen ob wir ersten Hochzeitstag haben
und vielleicht irgendwelche
Aufmerksamkeiten im Zimmer für uns zu
hinterlassen und natürlich sind wir
nicht wegen irgendeinem Hochzeitstag
oder so unterwegs aber es wurden
trotzdem Aufmerksamkeit im hinterlassen
einmal diese Karte dir Mister Henrichs
and Mr great please enjoy your journey
weathers best Pedro and Matthias
Training Manager hier wurden Matthias
wir danken euch ihr seid die besten
deutlich interessante aber auf dem sofat
folgendes Paket auf uns gewartet ich
habe tatsächlich noch nicht reingeschaut
wunderbar wir können wenn es Simplon
Orient gebrandete Umschläge Postkarten
und einfach Grüße aus dem Zug an unsere
Freunde und Familie schicken was eine
richtig coole Idee findet gerade für die
älteren Leute denen ist es sowas glaube
ich richtig was wert ziemlich coole
kleine Idee die Laune macht mich
ja schreibe ich vielleicht auch eine an
meiner Oma fast aber noch wichtiger als
das Zimmer ist die verpflegt der
Obstkorb und Kaviar am Anfang haben die
Latte schon ziemlich hochgesetzt aber
wie gut ist das Essen im speisemann
14 Uhr wir sind auf dem Weg zu unserem
ersten reservierten Tisch im Restaurant
Nummer eins wir sind richtig gespannt
keine Ahnung ob die hier direkt frisch
im Zug kochen oder nicht wir werden
gleich mal fragen ob wir noch einen
Blick in die Küche haben können jetzt
sind wir erstmal sehr aufs Essen
gespannt an Bord ist gibt es drei
verschiedene Restaurants loriental ich
wollte noch und das Restaurant in
welchem wir unser Land zu uns nehmen
werden Kurt nach frisch gebackenem Brot
mit orangen Meersalz Butter und dem
reichen von Weinen der literally an den
Reben wächst an dem wir in diesem Moment
vorbei gefahren sind haben die Vorspeise
also ist wirklich unglaublich deshalb
ist es unheimlich gut das Essen kam
sofort es gibt eine Menü an dass man
sich hält das wird natürlich angepasst
wenn man irgendwie Allergien oder so hat
wenn man das schmeckt und bekommt man
einfach das Tagesmenü serviert und wir
bekommen zur Vorspeise zum Brot mit
einem Oliven Dip und Garnelen oder so
Flusskrebse in so einer kleinen leichten
Suppe insgesamt vier Gänge ich bin
gespannt freue mich außerdem sieht hier
natürlich einfach unheimlich gut
aussieht man hat riesige
Lounge Feeling und hier wäre sogar Platz
für vier Personen also echt super
und sofort nach der Hauptspeise folgte
auch schon der Hauptgang Seebarsch mit
Fenchel und meeresfrüchtesauce die
Vorspeise hat super gut geschmeckt war
super leicht ne verdünnte Tomatensuppe
und jetzt hoffe ich dass der Hauptgang
in dem gleich kommen kann natürlich erst
der Geschmackstest habe ich von Max
gelernt erst einmal alles einzeln
[Musik]
bekommen sondern ich habe auch eine
halbe Flasche Wein getrunken
dementsprechend die sie und müde bin ich
groß auf euch und diese 17.000 €. okay
wir genießen das den vollen Zügen
genehmigen uns jetzt noch den Nachtisch
wir legen uns dann erstmal in unserer
Suite schlafen natürlich muss ich aber
noch einen Blick in die Küche erhaschen
und schauen ob das Essen wirklich frisch
zubereitet genau
war unglaublich lecker und das Erlebnis
die italienische vorgebirgslandschaft an
sich vorbeiziehen zu lassen wirklich
einmalig während ich mich gerade hier
aus dem Fenster gegangen habe um genau
diese thumbnail Fotos zu machen wurde
so vom anderen Fahrzeug zu rufen Dave
junge was geht so mitten in Italien
ja ja ihr habt mich beim thumbnail
versuchen
liebe Grüße während sich der Zug immer
weiter Richtung Paris bewegt kann man
seine Zeit mit einer Tasse Tee oder
Kaffee oder einem Nickerchen verbringen
oder man reflektiert über die Frage was
macht diesen Zug eigentlich besonders
wieso ist der Zug so teuer und wieso
gibt es einen Film über diese Reise der
Orient Express gilt als ein Revolution
des Reisens da 1883 erstmals eine
durchgängige Reise also ohne Umsteigen
zwischen verschiedenen Ländern und
Regionen möglich machen damals
insbesondere zwischen Paris und
Konstantinopel was wir heute als
Istanbul kennen die Reise dauerte
mehrere Tage und führte durch mehrere
Länder in Europa und Asien Florian
Express wurde dann schnell zu einem
Symbol für Abenteuer und exklusiv und
wurde von Königen Aristokraten
Diplomaten und reichen Geschäftsleuten
genommen mittlerweile gibt es viele
weitere Strecken und die Fahrt dauert
auch nicht mehr ganz so lange wie früher
Waggons erinnern von der Einrichtung her
aber immer noch an den Zug von damals
wieso ist der Zug aber heutzutage immer
noch so teuer weil es exklusiv ist weil
es das schon immer war und weil der Zug
Geschichte hat und irgendwie auch status
symbol ist kein Kaviar kein Champagner
und keine Dusche im Zimmer rechtfertigt
so einen Preis im Prinzip bezahlt man
die Geschichte mit und wieso gibt es
dazu den Film wenn der Zug zum einen
natürlich weltbekannt ist und
gleichzeitig einfach der perfekte
Schauplatz finden ist ein Mord in dem
Zug in dem viele Personen sitzen die
sich alle gegenseitig Verdächtigen und
man weiß dass es einer der Gäste gewesen
sein muss dazu ein Detektiv und fertig
ist der König
[Musik]
gerade schon gesehen habt wir sind jetzt
beim Abendessen tatsächlich sind die
Leute noch mal deutlich schicker
angezogen als heute Mittag wurde
eigentlich angefragt dass man mit viel
Büro erkrankt ist das haben wir jetzt
nicht aber wir sind ja jung und
sportlich zumindest deutlich deutlich
bekommen Artischocken auf irgendein
Creme mit irgendwas sieht unheimlich gut
aus und wenn das nur im Ansatz so gut
ist wie das Mittagessen da mache ich mir
überhaupt keine Gedanken auch wieder
drei Gänge
ist kalt ist unheimlich gutes weiter
ging es mit einem medium rare
angebratenen Filet mit Gratin Hut das
Gericht auch wieder unheimlich lecker
und wirklich umpoint den Abschluss macht
ein zahlreiche Käsesorten mit Früchten
und Marmeladen sowie ein Pistazien
zitronensorgehängt ein Wagen der schon
immer eine wichtige Rolle gespielt hat
und bisher noch nicht zur Sprache kam
ist der Barwagen gemütliche
Sitzmöglichkeiten eine vollwertige Bar
gute Drinks und Live Musik von einem
Baby grand piano machen den Wagen abends
zum play Story um den Tag im Orient
Express ausklingen zu lassen um ehrlich
zu sein habe ich mich aber ein bisschen
wie ein Fremdkörper gefühlt da mich
mindestens 40 Jahre von allen weiteren
Gästen getrennt haben nichtsdestotrotz
waren die Drinks wirklich hammer und die
Stimmung gut so schick angezogen zu sein
unter Leuten die auch alle ihre besten
Klamotten ausgepackt haben in einem so
geschichtsträchtigen Zug war einfach
irgendwie cool und man darf nicht
vergessen wir bewegen uns die ganze Zeit
wir fahren die ganze Zeit durch
verschiedene Kulissen und das ist das
was das Ganze ebenso besonders macht und
noch besonderer wäre es wenn die
Betreiber ihr wollt wirklich nicht
einhalten würden und man 24/7 Champagner
bestellen können
türkis
[Musik]
es ist Zeit ein Uhr nachts wir haben
ordentlich getrunken wir haben
ordentlich gegessen wir haben den ganzen
Tag den Zug erkundet ein wirklich
ereignisreicher Tag und jetzt freue ich
mich hier endlich ins Bett steigen zu
können und die letzten paar hundert
Kilometer Richtung Paris Schlafen zu
genießen ich wünsche euch eine
traumhafte Nacht
[Musik]
guten Morgen während hier draußen gerade
die Sonne aufgeht probiere ich irgendwie
in den Tag zu starten und das geht
natürlich am besten mit einer Dusche ich
werde jetzt in diesem Zug duschen
[Musik]
am Vortag hat mir die Möglichkeit unser
Frühstück aus einer großen Selektion
zusammenzustellen wir haben das aber
nicht so ganz verstanden und im
Endeffekt einfach alles bestellt
[Musik]
bei so viel essen mussten uns wirklich
beeilen weil wir fast schon in Paris
unsere Endstation angekommen waren
dennoch auch beim Frühstück wieder
höchste Qualität liebevoll hergerichtet
super frisch extrem lecker und
wahrscheinlich das beste Frühstück dass
ich jemals hatte und das in einem Zug
und mit der Einfahrt in den Pariser
Bahnhof der lässt endet unsere 22
stündige Reise mit dem wenn es Simplon
Orient Express in der großweed es war
ein absolutes fest wir haben gespeist
wie die Könige haben getrunken wie die
Könige wir haben genächlich wie die
Könige und allgemein was eine richtig
richtig verrückte Erfahrung das letzte
Mal durch den Gang wieder in Birkenstock
und
klamottenstein
hier noch nicht ganz vorbei
unser Zug zurück nach Deutschland fuhr
vom gardinand ein Bahnhof der etwa 200
Meter entfernt vom Garde lässt ist damit
wir diese Strecke aber nicht noch nach
unserer anstrengenden Reise laufen
mussten wurden wir vom Chauffeur in
einem 7er BMW in Empfang genommen und
auf den letzten Trip von Garde lässt zum
Garde noch im 7er BMW mit ordentlich
Beinfreiheit
wie auch beim Glacier Express in der
Schweiz schon bewerten wir Pünktlichkeit
Verpflegung Komfort experience
Sauberkeit und Preis
Pünktlichkeit 555 wo wurden abgeholt
alles war bestens organisiert wir wurden
mit dem Boot zum Bahnhof gefahren
abfahrt ab pünktlich Ankunft in Paris
pünktlich alles perfekt Verpflegung mehr
geht nicht Kaviar beim Einsteigen so
viel Champagner wie wir wollen Essen
frisch gemacht drei Gänge drei
verschiedene Restaurants also wirklich
das ist das Maximum mehr geht in einem
Zug nicht 55 Komfort was soll ich sagen
die gesamte Zugreise ist auf Komfort
ausgelegt eigenes großes Bett großes
Zimmer eigenes Badezimmer Dusche quasi
einen eigenen but und es wird sich um
alles gekümmern also Komfort auch hier
wieder 5 und 5 es kommt mir so vor als
hätten wir den besten Zug der Welt
getestet was wir haben
experience und hier wird es jetzt etwas
knifflig klar das war eine einmalige
Erfahrung die experience ist unglaublich
bei dem Zug fährt Geschichte mit man hat
viel Platz man geht in die Bar aber im
Endeffekt hat es sich so ein bisschen
angefühlt als hätte irgendwas auf dieser
Reise gefehlt was ich beim Glacier
Express nicht hatte
weiß ich nicht ich gebe viereinhalb von
fünf Sauberkeit haben wir im Hauptvideo
im hauptpark einfach rausgelassen weil
wir nichts gefunden haben das war
absolut uninteressant also 555 und damit
zur letzten und entscheidenden Frage
Preis wir haben 17.000 € für 22 Stunden
bezahlt
12,80 € pro Minute dass das völlig
absurd ist steht nicht zur Frage das
kann man machen wenn man absoluter Zug
Fan ist lohnt sich in keiner Welt für
niemanden außer man macht ein Video
darüber und kann ein paar Leute von euch
unterhalten die kleine Kabine hätte
vollkommen ausgereicht ich muss für den
Preis 1 0 0 5 geben wenn ich das Video
gefallen hat lasst mir gerne ein Like da
vielen Dank an die finden ohne die das
Video wirklich nicht möglich gewesen
wäre vergesst nicht den Kanal zu
abonnieren dann sehen wir uns in den
nächsten Wochen wieder vielleicht zu
einem Test eines Schlafzimmers aus ja
mach's gut ciao
[Musik]